um yeah so I'm going
to talk about sort of two two separate
things one is um an areial for 1D gaap
systems and the second is sort of the
emergence of this thing called
approximate ground state projections as
an object that seems sort of a helpful
tool it's used in this case but it's
also seems like it has more general
interest for approaching some of the
ongoing bigger questions so um okay so
let's sort of set most of you probably
know most most of this but let's sort of
set it up the you know the the
fundamental difficulty of understanding
many B VI physics is that you've got a
very very large space so each particle
is some D dimensional space and there
are n particles and the space that
you're talking about then is the tensor
product which is an exponentially large
space and the states that you're
interested in describing are some Vector
in this uh exponentially large space um
and so you've kind of got this D this uh
double Ed sort of that the you know if
you want you know the power of
quantum uh computation or sort of what
they can do what Quantum systems can do
is you know that's the good part the bad
part is if you want to try to understand
it you're trying to understand something
that's in a very very large space so
this is the
challenge
um even describing a single state if you
just took a random state in this
exponential large space is going to take
with too much for you to do anything
with
so that leads you to the sort of the
basic question well maybe I don't care
about all states maybe only I care about
some small set of them and are there is
there sort of some set of states that
are physically relevant and for which I
can sort of get out of this
exponentially
large problem um by
oops press the wrong
thing
yeah so sorry um so can we find sort of
a a a little corner of this big space um
where the states were interested in our
something physically relevant and for
which we have a better handle on them
and what do we mean by a better handle
well they have some sort of structure
you know can we find that structure um
is that structure good for you know we
have we're assuming we only have
polinomial size resources to deal with
it um so can we describe it in a
polinomial size way and does it also
allow us it's not enough to just
describe it we want to sort of work with
it and understand some properties of it
so can we do that so those are the basic
questions that we want want to um get to
so what are these physically relevant
States um this sort of corner that I'm
going to be focusing on um they're going
to be ground states of local hamiltonian
so let me just quickly go over what we
mean by a local hamiltonian and imagine
most of you know this
um so here we've got our particles laid
out in two dimensions and we imagine
that there are um the hamiltonian is
built up as a sum of terms that are
local and by local we mean geometric ly
local and in this case we mean um
they're acting on neighboring sites
right so they're only non-trivial on
neighboring sites they act sort of in
this case between those two and
otherwise they act like the identity and
you sum up these local operators and you
get what's called a local
hamiltonian and you're interested in the
ground state the lowest energy en state
or I States for for this hamiltonian um
the ground state is the lowest one and
we talk about a notion of a gap and the
Gap is you have an energy associated to
the lowest Dion State and then we um we
talk about how much distance between the
lowest and the second lowest so we'll
assume there's a unique lowest lowest
energy State and the Gap will refer to
the difference in energy between the
lowest Dion State and the second
lowest okay and so we're going to focus
on unique ground States so there's only
one lowest State and for which there's a
constant size Gap
so um this has a parameter of let's say
n in it in terms of their n terms or the
particles the length of the system or
the size of the system has a parameter
and Associated to it but we're going to
assume that the Gap remains is constant
in that situation not a function of
n okay and so the ground States the
reason we as as Frank sort of talked
about the reason we focus on ground
States is is that in lots of settings
the ground States model uh the systems
at low temperature
expect to get
out okay so remember so our our our
Quest right is to understand these
ground States and trying to find nice
compact ways of describing them and to
work with the
description okay so let me sort of give
you sort of what the result I'm going to
be telling you um today about is that
for gapped 1D systems the answer is yes
you have a nice structure turns out not
I'm not going to tell you that in fact
you uh you can do quite a bit with them
but I'm going to tell you some of what
you can do with them um and that's known
for 1D systems um it's believed that
there's nice structure in general but
nothing has been proven in in very in
any kind of generality for higher
Dimensions okay is it important that you
have a unique ground state uh it is
important in the sense that the results
we know are hold for unique
ground state so for for for ground
spaces it's not known there's some stuff
known but not
enough not
enough and it's an interesting
question okay so so um so now let me
tell you sort of what
uh what the kind of property I'm going
to sort of describe the kind of property
that we're looking looking for in terms
of ground states that sort of uh
physicists in general believe is true
for Gap systems um uh that sort of
limits the amount of that it's not sort
of as um the complexity of the states
are not as big as one could imagine they
are and it comes from a concept Mo U
motivated by the holographic principle
um and it's basically saying that the um
so well well let me just sort of put out
a system here um that if we take this so
this is a this is a system this is an
example in two Dimensions
um and the ground state of this
system um we can ask what what's what's
the um sort
of that well I guess most of you guys
know entanglement right so um if we if
if we look at a system and sort of ask
for the amount of entanglement between
some region and its complement that that
should scale like the size of the
boundary of the system rather than what
it typically could do which would be the
volume of the system so this is this
notion that that a state behaves this
way that it's that it's entanglement
scales like the boundary the size of the
boundary is known as an area La um and
uh was I guess so the speculation is or
the conjecture is
uh that ground states of Gap systems and
maybe not even just Gap systems um
should behave some version of an area so
behave According to some version of an
area law um and it was formulated in
terms of tanglement entrophy in
2001 because there sort of a notion of
complexity in general and so it sort of
we used uh sort of it was sort of firmed
up and made precise using entanglement
entropy and despite this being sort of a
a well believed
D
um idea um that that ground States
should behave this way uh in fact um it
took Hastings in in 2007 maybe a little
bit earlier to actually prove this
statement in 1D and that was a really a
breakthrough result um and so let me say
what what that statement is so in one
dimension what the area law would say is
that the entanglement from the left side
to the right side should depend depend
only on the size of the boundary in this
case the size of the boundary is one
right so we're saying that the
entanglement from left to right is
constant right whereas a typical just a
any an arbitrary state would typically
have entanglement on the order of
uh n where n was the number of particles
on the left or the
right right so the results said okay we
have an areial law for 1D but
furthermore it said something further
which is that we actually have a nice
description in terms of Matrix prodct
States a
polinomial
um uh polom bonded matrix product states
does good is a very good approximation
for
um uh these ground States um and
therefore if I give you you and if I
give you the matrix product State you
can work with it it's an efficient
description that you can actually work
with you can compute local energies so
you can actually verify that in fact it
it's you know what it's ground in energy
is if I give you the description and so
so that sort of classified this as in
terms of complexity as a problem that's
in
NP okay and so that led to sort of um
that leads to some very natural
questions and the natural questions is
you know okay so something's going on in
1D what happens in 2D can we use any of
these ideas for to go to 2D where we
really this is an open question in 2D
it's pretty much a very big open
question question Tod for matter physics
um it also led to another question which
is all right it's in NP but can we find
it right can we find these and so these
were the questions that um that were
sort of motivating us when we sort of
picked up this looked at this result and
um but in reality our biggest question
was could we sort of understand what was
going on and so these were in the
background but in the foreground was um
can we understand this result can we
understand what's going on and um so it
took a lot of work but um what emerged
out of sort of our attempts to
understand what's going on uh was the
idea of an approximate ground state
projection which I'm now going to sort
of describe and and then tell you why it
sort of tells you
what it's sort of the driving force from
the results that we we got and there's
this um so POA has some people there
he's quoted both as saying if there's a
problem you can't solve then there's an
easier problem you can't solve and he's
quoted as saying there's problem you
can't solve then there's an easier
problem that you can solve so um
depending on who you ask but anyway we
tried to we tried to find that and so
where we went to was say let's take
local hamiltonians but let's take them
where their actual terms commute right
okay so frustration free commuting so
we're going to take the local we're
going to assume we're in a situation
where the ground state satisfies each
term locally and furthermore that each
each of the local terms commute okay so
this is a sort of a lot of assumptions
here here it's meant to be an easier
problem but it's meant to give us some
sort of intuition as to what's going
on okay and so in that case we were
going to even go further and assume that
the local terms are
projections and if you do that then
there's a very
uh
simple statement which is that if you
want to describe the projection onto the
ground space just take one minus each of
the projections and multiply them
together and because those projections
commute the product of them will also be
a projection and what you'll be left
with is only the things it's going to
project exactly down onto the ground
space and if you take that projection
and just apply it to any product State
well you'll get something in the ground
space unless it happened to be that the
product state was actually orthogonal to
the ground space but if it's not you're
going to get some Vector you're going to
project
some simple Vector into the ground space
and you'll have something in the ground
space and so if you look at what that
looks like if you take a simple thing
and then you apply just local
projections where they all commute you
end up very quickly just with this
picture you've got a matrix product
state which describes something in the
ground
space okay
so this is in the frustration free case
but this really hinges on the fact that
you take this product of
projections and this again is a
projection
so you can take this product of
projections it's again a projection and
it's mapping you into the space so okay
so that's that's our that's our starting
point so so what you know what does this
sort of lead us to well how do we kind
of generalize this idea and the
generalization of this idea is we're
going to look for something that does
its best to project into the ground
space okay and that's what an
approximate ground sa projection so do
you need a gap for this argument no but
in the commuting case they'll
automatically be a gap if you were to
assume projections you don't need a gap
and you don't need a unique ground space
but the Gap will be there but the unique
ground space won't but
but okay so so we're going to instead of
finding a projection we're going to find
something that acts like a projection
okay and so what do we mean by that this
is what approximate ground state
projection that's what the term is going
to mean HP so what it's going to mean is
that in the direction of the ground
space when it's going to be a linear
operator that in the direction of the
ground space it's going to leave it
alone and in every other direction it's
going to cut it
down so that's what we mean by
approximately
projecting right so it's going to leave
the ground space alone and it's going to
shrink everything else but we also want
a second property out of it which is
that it isn't too complex as an
operator and that lack of complexity so
if we go back to the commuting case it
was important that this product
here across any cut this product only
had one term and that's what led to the
fact that this matrix product state
representation had a small Bond
Dimension right so we want to mimic that
sort of non not too complex idea cross
any okay so those are the two properties
that in in a big picture way we're
looking for we're looking for something
that shoots us towards the ground space
or the ground state and but and and and
cuts things down away from it and while
doing so doesn't doesn't add too much
complexity to to the
setup okay and so this notion so let me
now let me just sort of jump ahead for
the the view from far away what's it led
to so this this agsp well it led us to a
new uh proof of the 1D area law with um
with an exponential Improvement on the
parameters in terms of um uh in terms of
what the entropy was and one of the
things so there are a couple things that
it led to but one of the things that led
to was that the matrix product State
description now you could describe the
bond Dimension was now sublinear and
once the bond Dimension was sublinear
there sort of a standard uh uh algorithm
for if you know that the bond Dimension
was sublinear to get a sub exponential
time algorithm for finding the solution
so this was a little bit this was
surprising and um kind of gave us hope
that maybe something better was even
true that we could actually find it um I
guess also I'll talk about it a little
bit later the parameters are such
for the 1D area law that they're really
at the cusp of doing something
interesting when we try to apply them to
2D so any little
Improvement can get us a a non-trivial
statement about 2D uh structure and the
second result was then that in fact by
using a different set of approximate
ground state projections and uh not an
argument necessarily in fact it was a
different agsp from the ones used here
and the ones used here wouldn't work we
actually came up with a polinomial time
algorithm for finding solutions to
Gap all right so this is just to sort of
say hey look we think that this notion
of an agsp is an important one we think
it's sort of we kind of have some
demonstrations of what it's saying so
far and we think that maybe it's really
the way of thinking or the new tool for
thinking about uh is this for the
hamiltonian which is a sum of commuting
projectors or is this no no this is in
general sorry this is in general for the
yeah the some commuting one we've done
and we're happy with and yeah so this is
down
um yeah so so we really sort of our
picture now feels like the agps are
important they're a nice contuct they
have interesting properties and and they
really are telling us something that um
is worth looking into for for the next
set of questions that come
up um okay and so this is just sort of a
picture uh in in 1D of what's s of this
is how I see it right so that there are
there are sets of local Hamil uh local
1D hamiltonians for which agps exist and
those should give us simulation and
areal law results there are others for
which areal law results are true but
where agps do not exist and those are at
least in my mind those are going to
still be hard we're not going to be able
to be able to do much with those
ones okay so now let me give you an
overview of the proof of the area law
first I'm going to go from very big
picture and then I'm going to sort of
take each of the two steps can you go
back to the previous uh slide so you're
saying that you know
that there are cases where the agsp
doesn't exist and is an area well we
know there are cases where there there
is an area law for which uh finding it
is uh hard so and those are necessary
neily going to be cases where is there a
Criterion for whether it's finding the
HSB is easy or
hard
um well let's see so we you know our
situation is when is for for which a
when there is a gap so when there's a
gap we can find an HSP and I guess it's
it's an open question whether there are
other scenarios where we can find you're
saying there could be non Gap States
where there's an area low the
entanglement but there wouldn't be an
HS
so what's are the parameters for the
polom
time ah good question so they're not no
nobody has attempted
to let's see do we know what they are
even approximately what are they for
yeah so so the the main the main issue
is the dependence on Epsilon which is
which is you know so so it's a it's a
polinomial where the where the exponent
is a function of uh of the local
Dimension and
and I think it's uh it's
uh isn't it exponential in log log
of log of the local dimension of epon is
is the
exponent that right so the Gap does not
come in I'm sorry the Gap does not come
in the Gap is ABS the Gap
is so in the many body localized regime
there are excited states which have area
low and triangle B there's no energy gap
but nonetheless there a sort of Mobility
Gap so have you thought or all about
whether ASP procedure mic
work anything
else okay so now
um I me so to now going to spend the
rest of the time sort of going first
going over sort of bird's eye view of
the pro proof of of the area law and
then sort of seeing where and seeing
where the asps fit in and then spending
some time uh understanding the
constructions of the
agps okay so the areal L proof is is
sort of from a schematic point of view
is is is
uh is the following um first we find a
not very complex state that has some
inner product with the ground space
that's uh ground state that's that's
some constant
but not necessarily a very good constant
right so we get something non-trivial
out of a very non- complex
State product state in it in actuality
and then we repeatedly apply this
agsp okay and what is the adsp
repeatedly applying going to do is every
time we apply it we're going to move it
closer to the ground state but we add
some complexity but it'll turn out that
because where we started was close
enough that the repeated App application
of the agsp will get us to a very good
approximation without introducing too
much
complexity now so that's is I sort of
made it clear how the second step is
going to use the AGB actually the first
step the step is the harder step and
this is the step for which uh the
original proof used a different monogamy
of entanglement type idea to get a to
get a a non-trivial in product and we're
actually going to use an agsp to show a
non-ul product and that AGP going to
give us a much better
non-ul okay and that's the the first one
is the the much more delicate
one okay so I've been sort of saying PL
complexity I mentioned entanglement anop
but in fact what we're going to sort of
deal with in this in this the only thing
we're going to sort of deal with in
terms of complexity is entanglement rank
right so it means the number of
coefficients we're going to sort of keep
track of complexity in terms of the
number of Schmid Co nonzero Schmid
coefficients we needed to describe um a
state across a particular cut and so in
this case U we're going to depict it by
this picture and the C suggests that I
can write this thing as a sum of a sum
of just C terms with a of of product
one and we'll also uh not only talk
about entanglement rank of States but
we'll take talk about entanglement rank
of
operators okay and then tangl manic rank
so an operator right sort of uh where
it's exactly the same concept which is
that it'll have entanglement rank C if I
can write it as a sum of C things where
it's an operator on the left Tor an
operator on the
right so let's just sort of just be
clear on what the behavior is when I
sort of take States or operators and how
does the entanglement rank affect so
um okay so if I apply an operator of
intangle rank let's say d to a state of
intangle rank C the result is intang
rank no more than C *
D and this is just simple than your
algebra and uh if I apply two if I
compose two operators of inang rank C
and D the inang rank of the product is
CD you can just sort of write that out
um and if on the other hand I'm summing
two states if I want some linear
combination of the two states then the
the um the tangular rank is additive
so it sort of gives us sort of we can
sort of Now sort of think about this in
terms of pictures and we just know that
if you're adding through things theang
ran Edge If you're sort of sticking them
one on top of the other then
they okay and so um okay so now let's go
to how we construct this AGP and what
this ASP is going to look like and so
let me remind you we are looking for an
operator with two prop properties the
first is that it approximately projects
onto the ground state the second is that
it's not too complex so let me just sort
of explain this diagram right so if I
write down the values of the uh if I
sort of write down the I values of the
agsp I want the ground state so if I lie
the ground state which I'm going to sort
of set at zero I want the ground state
to have I value one and I want all the
other values to be below
some Delta which we'll just call a Delta
parameter so that's the notion that we
shrinking the or Al Direction by Delta
and I'm preserving the ground
state and the second uh thing that I
want is that the complexity is not too
big and what I mean by the complexity
not too big is that I want its uh
entanglement rank to be I'm going to
just sort of encode the amount of
complexity as its entanglement rank
across a particular cut and we'll call
that parameter D so I have so with my
operator K I'm going to have two uh
parameters one is Delta which is the
amount that I shrink and one is D which
is the complexity and it'll turn out
what I'm looking
for is a critical threshold of
construction for which D * Delta is less
than one and it'll turn out that if I
can find such an operator with d * Delta
less than one then I have an
area okay and so that's this statement
here okay if I can find an AIS P for
which D * Delta is less than 1/2 or any
any constant less than one is fine
then the ground state has entropy order
of log D and that's true in any
Dimension let me sort of go over that
proof it's um uh not so hard okay so
here's the idea here's my ground state
and let me start with some product state
so remember the the idea of proving an
areial law is first to find a product
state with a nice inner product with the
ground state meaning a constant and a
product with the ground state and then I
repeatedly apply the HSP to get really
close but the hard hard part is getting
the nice inner product with the ground
state for something with not too much
entanglement so let me just start with
something with not too much entanglement
that's not so great all right so I'll
take a product St state which I can
depict like this because it doesn't have
any entanglement across this cut the
product State a Time B right and it
doesn't have it's not you know it's it's
got a tiny little overlap with it so let
me see whether I can do any better so
what am I going to do I'm going to apply
to that state the agsp so if I apply to
any state the ASP it moves things closer
to the ground state so let me do
that so I've applied the ASP here it's
moved things closer to the ground state
but it's added
entanglement but let me see let me do
something which is let me take that
entanglement and let me rewrite it let
me cut it into D pieces right so this is
now a state that has D it's decomposable
as this as some linear combination of D
pieces that are each
unentangled right and it was sitting
here and it turns out when D Delta is
less than one I'm guaranteed that one of
those D pieces has better inner product
than the original one as long as the
original one wasn't very close right so
that I I can break this up into D pieces
and one of those D pieces is a better
simple state
for uh inner product with the ground
space with the ground
state Okay so well now I've got a prime
B Prime I can just do the same thing and
I can keep going until that property
which is that when I break it up into
deep pieces I'm guaranteed that at least
one of those pieces is going to do
better until I run into a barrier for
that and it turns out that I run it into
a barrier for that at something
like approximately one over D something
like that okay so now I'm sitting here
let's assume that this red one now is
that one that I've pushed it as far as I
can go right that's I'm now done with my
step one of the of the outline right my
step one was to find something with
reasonably good inner product with the
ground space and I've got that and now I
apply a high power a higher power of the
agsp which will move me very close and
quickly because I've already got a
constant in our product how quickly well
it only take order log n applications of
it and if I only apply order login
applications of it right then I'm only
going to add this amount of entanglement
to it B to the order log in so I'm only
going to add polinomial amount
ofle and so what do I get I get a very
good approximation to the ground
state with only polinomial amount of
intang and that's what I wanted to
that's what I wanted to show and in fact
if I do the calculation careful the
polinomial turns out to be
sublinear okay so all right so stepping
back right what do I do I said let's
suppose we have an agsp for which D
Delta is less than a half now you can
kind of see how you use use it just
prove an area law right but we haven't
said anything about how to construct
that HD so now we're going to go through
and go through the ideas of constructing
that
adsb can you try to VI the intuition for
why there exists such an a prime and B
Prime yeah so um oh intuition at all why
why why if you break this uh one out of
the these D parts has a better uh
overlap why does one out of the D Parts
have a better overlap yes I can that I
can
so we've improved the in product by
quite a bit okay if I break this into D
pieces inner product is linear so if I
break this into D
pieces
the you
know there's an the inner product is
just linear the same in the inner
product so the average you know so so
the average increase is good enough to
have been an improvement
and so one of the one of the K terms
will one of the D terms will have
behaved like the average at least as
good as the
average is that is that okay so it's
really just relying on the fact that you
know if I have a sum of vectors and
their inner product is something good
then at least one of them is as good as
one over D of it right so basically one
of these guys is as good as one over D
of the Improvement but the Improvement
was one over Delta and so together this
D Delta gets you because the Delta is
less than a half that says that your
actual Improvement is is you've doubled
you essentially doubled your your um the
the inner product that you
have okay all right so now I'm going to
spend some time talking about the ideas
that go into constructing this
agsp okay so just as a as a preview the
agsp will turn out to be essentially a
polinomial in the hi in the local terms
okay um and to construct it we're going
to have we're going to use three key
sort of Concepts yeah sorry I thought we
were working with the general Hiltonia
not the sum of commuting projectors so
they're not commuting but they're
local so they're non-commuting
non-commuting local local
projection yeah so we're still in the
class of local
hamiltonians but we're just not assuming
they're commuting
anymore okay so the there's uh
just to preview there're going to be two
con two concepts in the construction one
is going to be a notion of a truncation
of of what I'm thinking about so a
cutting down of Norm away from the place
that I'm looking at the analysis so of
the local terms but not the local terms
near where I'm doing the analysis that's
going to be one of the things and we'll
go we'll cover it more carefully in a
minute the second is going to be the use
of CHF polinomial which will somehow get
us a good uh um sort of the best we can
do in terms of blowing up the Gap given
some
some some sort of to improve our
parameter Delta and the last thing that
we'll need is an analysis of essentially
the entanglement rank of um a power of
you have a sort of local term and that
raised to the elf power we're going to
sort of a monomial when need to do an
analysis of theang rank
of so that's just I mean I'm just giving
preview of what we're going to do but so
let's just pretend that we didn't know
how what we were going to do and let's
just sort of say what's the what's the
first natural thing to do so remember
we're looking for something which keeps
the ground state fixed and shrinks
everything
else so one thing you could do is say
well what what thing what operator do I
know you know en codes the ground state
well H itself has a smallest Dion value
the ground state so if I took one minus
it or I would make that the biggest and
so let's see what I what I want to
actually do is I have to sort of
normalize it but I could take 1 - H
divided by its norm and raise it to the
AL power and what would that look like
right so I would let's imagine uh this
is this is essentially what see what did
I draw
here this diagram isn't quite right but
if I took one minus H over uh Norm of H
to the L then this Gap so what I'm
interested that allows me to have sort
of a one for the for the ground state
and my Delta is going to turn out to be
1us Epsilon H to
the okay so I'm going to have a Delta so
so a Delta that's not particularly large
um but it's 1us Epsilon over H
to okay so that's my first candidate so
now if I think about how big that is
well the norm of H right if it's got n
terms in it I can only really
approximate that by an order n kind of
thing so this is 1 - Epsilon n raised to
the L power so you know uh it's not
particularly large it's rather small
right so and now sort of want to think
about how I can sort of improve that
and
um I can also ask I can also ask the
question of how much entanglement have I
put in and we're going to for the moment
it's helpful to think of just the power
of L as the amount of entanglement so I
want a small I want L to be small for
the entanglement to be small I want this
parameter to be big so I want a
combination of L to be small and this
parameter to be
big so now I have to think about ways of
making it better well the first thing
that you can see is that the bigger this
is the worse Delta
gets and so is there a way right for me
to make this Norm of age
smaller and this is is where the idea of
truncation comes along so how can we
make Delta Delta smaller without
increasing L and the way we do it is
what we do is we we don't want to lose
the local structure of this 1D local
structure near where we're going but
really the the contributions to the norm
of H away from
there that's just hurting us without
really helping us in any way so let's
try to just truncate that so what I mean
by that is have written this local
system that us to be on a line but now
I'm going to take all the terms that
sort of acted over here and I'm going to
say you know the sum of all those terms
had some big Norm to it but I'm going to
truncate that I'm going to cut that off
I'm going to say instead I'm going to
replace that with something that's Norm
is bounded by um some
constant I'm going to do that the same
thing over on the left side right of
course that makes the um that makes it
very non-local out here and out there
but I'm going to only use the local part
in here so that's okay and so I have to
worry what happens when I truncate this
thing do I change the operator a lot do
I change the um in particular do I
change what the ground state looks like
if I change what the ground state looks
like then if I change the problem I'm
going to be going to a ground state that
that's has no relation to the one that I
was originally starting with but it
turns out that we can show that in fact
if you truncate away from here you're
very very close and the ground state is
very very close to the ground state that
you were looking for
okay so that has the property so let's
call H Prime this new hamiltonian which
is the local terms around where I'm
looking but outside are these truncated
guys okay and the purpose of doing that
was we've made this Norm now instead of
this Norm being of order n we' made it
order of a constant okay there sort of
there s terms here that can contribute
up to S and then we'll cut this off at
some constant T and so we'll make all
this stuff a constant so that's a
prettyy big Improvement right
so that's our first
Improvement and our second Improvement
is we can say you know we took 1 minus H
over its Norm to the elf power
but that was just one choice right that
sort of had the property of keeping
things fixed and and smooshing down
everything else but maybe there's a
better choice of something that keeps
things fixed than smooshing down
everything else sry what do you get with
the previous
one um if you don't change if you don't
uh you do not get a ASP with d Delta
less than one it just doesn't give you
anything so we can we can talk about
choosing a better polinomial and what's
the pols that are sort of well suited
for this this is chf's pols CHF polins
come in sort of all over the place right
but what what is their basic feature is
they are pols who do the best job
of keeping things sort of even and small
or between minus one and one in a sort
of even way between the X values minus
one and one right but if you constrain
things to be very very nice and easy and
and uh sort of even in this region it
necessarily means that the second and
you do that optimally it necessarily
means that outside of this region this
thing shoots up as fast as it can right
and that's exactly what we want to use
right we want to use the fact that we
want to put our leading I value up here
and then we want to squeeze our Delta in
this region right so that's what we want
to use we want to use a scaled and
shifted version of a CHF poome okay and
that's exactly what the construction is
it's a scaled version and shifted
version of the CHF polinomial on now
instead of H on H
Prim and so that's improved uh and the
result of that improves our Delta by a
square root it turn out by a square root
factor in the in the um exponent in the
following sense right Delta now whereas
before it depended on L over the norm of
H now it depends on L over the sare root
of the
norm okay so this is our parameter for
Delta and so now our our so we've now so
this is our candidate this is our HP we
figured out what our Delta parameter is
now we have to figure out what our D
parameter is what our complexity is and
for a d parameter well it's a polinomial
in h Prime of degree L and so our
analysis is um is just going to be let's
just analyze what a sum of local terms
ra to the elf power is let's see what
its complexity is what is its
entanglement rank across a particular
C okay and if we can do that for H Prime
to the L well then some linear
combination the CHF polinomial is a
specific linear combination but I can
just you know that's only going to add a
factor of L CU I'm going to add up a
bunch of things and the contag rank is
only going to go up by a factor of L and
that in terms of what we're worried
about that's not a big cost at all so
we're just interested in a s in just H
Prime raised to the AL power and
remember what H Prime was it was a sum
of local terms plus two big terms at the
end
right okay so picture raising that to
the L power and multiplying it
out and so each of the local terms each
of of what we've got left will be a
product of the
hi are product
of individual ages so I've tried to
depict that here so maybe the first term
was you know this H and then maybe we
had that H then we had that one that one
that one that one okay so this is just
thinking of one term of course there are
an exponential number of terms but let's
just look at the entanglement rank of
one of these
terms okay and so I've got this sort of
a
picture of this product some particular
product
and if I look across some cut if I look
across a typical cut I'm going to see
the average number of terms that I would
expect to cross over that cut and I've
got sort of the number of terms here is
L right because it's a product raised to
the L power and I'm looking over a
section of length s that was the amount
that I kept of my line okay so there s
Slots of which I see l things and so I'm
going to see on the average l s terms
across a particular cut so let me find
one cut that has L terms and each term
contributes an entanglement rank of d^2
that's just just its local the local
Dimension Square so once I find that
typical location where it's average
number of Cs the amount of entanglement
across that is d 2 L 2 L S okay now that
cut might not have been the place that I
wanted to do the analysis right I'm
trying to do an analysis of a particular
cut and I just said look there was a
line of s terms and I'm saying one of
those guys is going to have a nice thing
but it might not have been the one that
you were we were worried about so I'm
going to have to pay some cost for
moving back and forth so here's this red
line is hey I actually wanted to know
what the entanglement rank was across
here right not across where you put your
green line so I have to pay a penalty
I'm GNA have to sort of move over I'm
gonna have to sort of estimate this
entanglement Rank by sort of moving over
here estimating it here and then moving
back okay and the cost of moving over is
a factor of D each time so I'm going to
have to pay and they're possibly S I
might have you know I might it might be
the leftmost one I might have been
sitting on the rightmost one so I have
to pay at least I might have to pay as
much much as D to the S to go and I
might have to pay as much of D to the S
to come back or maybe it's D to the S
total sorry it's I might have had to pay
D the s/2 to go and D the S over2 to
come back and so my total entanglement
rank across the red line is d 2 L / S
Plus
s so that's my Factor capital D I've
already got my Factor Delta right and
I'm looking for whether I can satisfy B
* Delta is less than a
half okay however there's something that
I swept under the rug right which was I
did an analysis of a single
term but they're an exponential number
of terms so if I want to actually at the
moment if this approximation was for a
single term so then if I added over an
exponential number of terms which is s l
I would have this front factor of s l
which is way too big so that's no good
but it turns out that I can do some
clever groupings of these terms so that
in fact I can split it up so that this
analysis is right and yet the number of
terms that I'm dealing with are these
big blocks of terms and the number of
terms that I'm dealing with is only um
is much smaller so much smaller that I
don't have to I can just disregard
them okay and that's where polinomial
interpolation comes in and I'm not going
to sort of it's it's it's I don't think
I have time it's clear I don't have time
for that what happened to the big terms
you don't care about the you have two
big terms the left and the right yeah so
the left and the right good question
right the left and the right if I'm
doing if I'm looking around the L slots
that I'm in the left turn acts only on
the left side which is way which is to
the left of where I'm looking and the
right term looks to the right of where
I'm looking so where I'm looking those
don't contribute anything to the
entanglement
R does that make sense so maybe I guess
that's worth saying right notice that if
I apply an operator that just acts on
the left right I don't change the
entanglement
rank of across the I mean I don't I
don't make it bigger I can't make it
bigger
okay so as I mentioned that sort of in
the naive expansion you've got too many
yes seems
Anis
dep yeah that's right this is just an
analysis of a local a local thing raised
to the AL power doesn't depend at all on
the CH where does the CH in the Delta
Factor it doesn't it doesn't come into
any polinomial will have this this
estimate of its entanglement Rank and
it's just that the CHF polinomial
allowed our Delta to be a little bit
smaller can I ask yeah do you know that
the Delta is exed
by yes I think we do do we really or do
we it has the property that uh if you
want to if you want to confine it to
under Delta in that region and you want
you know then this is the unique
polinomial which maximizes the the the
rate at which the bomal climbs outside
that region so you want it to be in a
tube and outside of the tube it grows as
fast as possible but but we wanted you
know we wanted to be uh to have value
one at uh you know at uh in the ground
state so we want uh we wanted to shoot
up to one as quickly as possible as low
as possible and it's a unique Pol
like all right
so okay so there so there too many terms
but we can deal with them in this sort
of
nice okay so let's try to put these two
things together right so remember what
are we searching for we're searching for
a construction of an operator for which
D * Delta is less than a half the top is
sort of my attempt to summarize what
what did we do here we truncated which
moved this made this smaller and then we
used a CHF polinomial and the result was
this Delta which was e to the uh order
minus l s okay and the entanglement
analysis yielded about this order and so
if you put those two things together you
get sort of this picture and if you
choose s to be about log s d then you
get at that point you get the you know
the minus s^ three Hales out out working
the S log D and uh you get something
less than one and so you get and because
whenever we have D Delta less than one
we get a we get an area law um the area
law turns out to be uh otia of logd over
Epsilon what it ends up
being okay
so so that's the whole that's that's the
whole uh proof
so okay so let me finish up by saying
sort of okay so what where does this
leave us right so this leaves us in a
couple of interesting places but the the
main one that I think is sort of is
worth taking away is that these agps now
as ideas are sort of have been kind of
demonstrated both in in this areal law
proof and in the um in the simulation
which was not covered here at all and
there are two different distinctly
different kinds of asps with different
properties in the simulation you're not
interested in D Delta less than a half
you're interest you're actually you
actually are um it isn't nice that you
have this feature that away from the cut
things are um you can't you can't just
truncate the way that you did in the
other one because you care about the
local structure all the way through for
simulation results but but the the sort
of picture is that the asps are sort of
really sort of coming out as this tool
for sort of saying something about
Quantum anybody systems certainly in 1D
and our hope is sort of that that this
kind of expands to looking at things
about 2D so what's the status of 2D well
right now if we take remember those were
sort of our original questions was sort
of how to see whether we can understand
this stuff enough to sort of look at the
2D picture so right now it's kind of the
bearest of no news right so it's sort of
if you take these ideas and just apply
them in the most straightforward way to
2D systems you get something that is at
the cusp of showing something
interesting so if you could improve it a
little bit somehow you would have a sub
volume law for 2D that would that also
give you any kind of improvement in
terms of how to represent it like you
have the MPS result for Wy now would
this Improvement also give you anything
about representing the ground state say
as a tensor product or would you get an
analogous Improvement in terms of
representing the state is there anything
that you can
say let's see if we could do an
improvement here
so I think if we could do an improvement
here it would sort of it would say that
you could
represent a 2d state with some Bond
Dimension that was less than the one you
would need for to describe any state by
some
amount that's stronger than than just
the area LA to actually be able to
factor it to sort of say that you have
an approximation with yeah uh yeah and I
think the same ideas would yes I think
that that would be fine right
to
check a good
question I think that's okay
but since we don't have since we don't
yet have an
improvement you say any improvement with
suffice are you thinking of treating the
2D system as ofd system going
reg uh sort of crushing it in one
dimension yeah but but then wouldn't log
D be the length in that direction that
you crushed
you're crushing a whole column into one
point right yeah so L would be the L in
that direction right
yeah
beb yeah so so it require okay so if you
just naively apply it that would get you
something not so good but what you want
to do is go back to the um to
the uh the analysis of the
entanglement so to go back to this
picture right so this picture
you want to do the cut analysis but now
you want to now you want to use the 2D
structure as well so whereas just
crushing it with sort of say anytime I
apply something I have to pay a cost of
D to the
n i now want to sort of instead write it
as a sum of things and then I don't have
to pay as big a cost maybe there's
another way of saying it which is
instead of instead of using you know
what you were suggesting where you take
each column as a
constraint um well then your your agsp
would be in those constraints but now
you're completely missing out on the
locality of that
column instead if you if you let the AGS
you know if you define the ASP to
respect that locality then you see
instead of L Cub you get down to l
s so now you're you're exactly at the
cusp of uh showing something long
Tri so so so then if you it's instead of
L Cub D over Epsilon which is a current
bound if you could you could say log to
the 3us
Delta um Epsilon then you would get a
sub
volume okay um the other other
directions to go is um we do have a
right so we currently have a um an
algorithm for for finding these ground
States in 1D but it's highly non-local
in the sense that you
um you kind of have to keep track of
everything while you're doing it um and
there's reason to think that maybe what
would be nicer right is if somehow you
could be uh in your algorithm you could
only have to deal with little bits of
the state at any one time rather than
keeping track of everything and that's
the sense in which I mean a a more local
algorithm in 1D and what that what that
seems to point to is getting some sort
of
um
uh some sort of ASP construction that
doesn't have this feature of uh again of
truncating away in uh what we sort of
need was that D Delta would be need to
be less than a half across one of the
cuts and then way away from things it
couldn't it wouldn't have it would have
to be not too bad and right now too bad
this truncation that we do is too bad
that's the sense in which sort of uh you
know that's another direction to go with
these things and then there are a couple
items just to talk about of independent
interest one is just this argument
of um you know as you pointed out it
doesn't involve the Chach polinomial
right but uh this this General argument
about powers of the entanglement of
powers of a local operator right and we
found that that sort of the entanglement
sort of scaled like square root of L and
uh rather than L and so that's sort of
reminiscent of a kind of random walk
Behavior right the added in tanglement
of HDL is on the order of Ro H dun l
soth I think it's worth thinking about
that a bit see what whether that has
something um interesting it certainly
was surprising when we kind of figured
it out um and the the final thing of
Interest I think is the
um is uh this result that I didn't
really say much about I just said you
truncate on the outsides but then I sort
of said hey look when you truncate on
the outsides the ground state is very
close to the ground state that you
actually started with um and that idea
that there's a robustness of this TR
truncation that you're sort of keeping
the structure even though you're you're
truncating I think that's a an
interesting thing to think about we stop
there aou
questions so what breaks with the
degenerate so good
question
so okay so what doesn't break is um the
fact that you can find one State uh that
is uh that hasn't satisfies an area law
in the in the so in the in the system
where there's a degenerate ground space
and still a gap you can find
uh a at least one state with the with an
AAL L that was proven by 10 just
recently um but now if you try to do a
second state it's not so easy because
what you're worried the reason is you
want to sort of apply the same argument
which is to sort of try to get a product
State that's reasonably close right but
you don't really know whether in that
process of finding that product State
you're actually running yourself right
back into the first one that you already
found right and if you don't want to run
back yourself back into the first one
then you have to sort of try to remain
orthogonal to that and that becomes more
complicated but these are really
interesting I mean we're we're thinking
about the ground state question because
I think it's an interesting question and
I think it's also interesting to think
about
what what kind of aerial law statement
might you hope to even say in the case
where there's a ground space rather than
a ground
state
so uh let's see we we'll break to two uh
for lunch um so again you know for
people who are not not from here in
terms of lunch options there are many
places close by on both sides of campus
and also they on campus so there are
fers outside about can find you know
where you can go to lunch and or you can
just lch on to somebody Lo and
find